would you say that I am a prompt person
you are you're very prompt you don't
like being late I don't like being late
I like to be prompted my call time for
this show was 3 30 here at Sirius yeah
XM and I'm always someone that checks my
apps to make sure how long is it going
to take to get there I want to get there
at 3 30 so there's time to get some
makeup on because I need the makeup as
you can attest this crowd is you saw me
close up right some of you backed away
and said yeah what's wrong with that
pumpkin
that's a pumpkin from last Halloween
oh no it's rotting quickly in the Autumn
Sun anywho I like to be here on time and
guys like to get the makeup I like to
relax do my do my stretches whatever I
need to do to get into the space to do
this podcast that I love doing so much
um I check my app about uh two o'clock
and it said or whatever quarter to two
and it said oh plenty of times it's
going to take you like half an hour to
get there because I live on the other
side of town okay great yeah it won't be
a problem for 40 minutes then I'm taking
my time I leave that amount of I leave
plenty of time I want to actually get
here early I get in my car and I check
and it says it's going to take an hour
and 28 minutes oh to get there and it
suddenly changed I didn't know what
happened
I'm trying to get here and there's
police all over the place and I stop I I
rolled down my window and addressed the
policeman I said hey Kappa no that's
weird that's
not that was wrong Century I said um
excuse me officer what's going on and he
said oh there's a cougar that's roaming
around in this area that got that's
that's been cited and so we're shutting
down all the streets and so we can say
and we've called in
um you know Wildlife people to make sure
that the cougar is safely caught and of
course the first thing I thought of was
a woman about 58. yeah with a white
glass of wine who's wandering around
this part of Los Angeles and there's
guys in helicopters trying to fire blow
darts at her yeah that tranquilizer but
her tolerance she's probably got like
nine darts but her tolerance for white
wine is so strong yeah she just sucks it
right down and every 25 year old man is
like hiding behind closed doors yeah
they're all up in the trees hiding oh no
here comes but anyway he said cougar I
don't know if it's a cougar a bobcat uh
but it was roaming around round and it
kind of blew my mind because I thought I
grew up on the east coast in
Massachusetts
nature no animal I mean a snowstorm
would but no animal ever affected my
schedule I don't think my my schedule
was ever altered in any way by an animal
that's something that can happen here in
La I've got to get somewhere oh yeah but
a bear has different ideas or a bobcat
or a giant hawk descended on the highway
and tore someone's face off we've got to
close everything down for a while that's
something I dreamed when I did acid
um that's not a real thing that happened
I just it's a cougar or yeah is it that
bad I think they were trying to look
after the cougar but also he said
there's a school near here oh and I
thought you guys Gotta Eat you know oh
man well I'm sorry did you say I really
have to get to Sirius XM and officer
officer I'm a celebrity
I know these others have to wait around
but I'm a celebrity with the podcast you
see
so I would like it if you gave me an
escort I really would love it I've
always wanted
it would just enrage people but if I
could get you know the one you see in
movies sometimes someone takes a siren
and just a guy who's in a regular
looking car he gets a call because he's
undercover or something and he just puts
that siren on top of his car and I've
always wanted one of those and put it on
the car and start barreling through
traffic and people get out of the way
and then someone at one point be like
what the [ __ ] that say celebrity can you
imagine
how mad people would be at me how and
rightfully so I mean you know what I
mean yeah no I would be mad at you if
you did that test with what's the worst
thing I could do I know and in that
moment when everyone else was
respectfully waiting for the cougar I
wanted to go I'm coming through
celebrity podcast
well you would have been here on time
yeah well still yeah I don't think
anyone knew anything was up okay you
know the crowd probably thought okay
we're starting just a couple of minutes
late
um you know and Conan's no spring
chicken they probably got to do some
work on him oh my God
front row
they got a really good look at me
no I think you're fine I still think
it's an overreaction for a cougar but I
don't know I live where there's bears
and stuff so I don't know maybe have you
seen a bear near your house yes all the
time you act like he's you come down and
he's having coffee at your table
he knows my name oh yeah
yeah
sort of talks like Elmo but not really
that was a terrible bear voice
what do you think a bear would sound
like like this it's uh it's more up in
this range right here no I think it's
like I'm a priest had a lot of berries
and they've worn away the acid and the
berries are worn away at his back part
of his throat hey Sona do you have this
is fine but do you have almond milk
regular milk it kind of triggers a
reaction it's not bad he's lactose
intelligence
oh my God yeah oh that Bear's side yeah
yeah that bear sucks well I'd like to
talk about Chevy
[Laughter]
that's something we can both agree on
that
you know why I want to talk about Chevy
why the Chevy family of electric
vehicles you know what they have
something for everybody they do yeah and
that's saying something yeah I'll tell
you right now it's an impressive
Spectrum that's right I use the word
spectrum of vehicles that are available
now you can buy now Reserve now stay
tuned because new vehicles are coming
that's what I like I like because I you
know back in the day you know I had a an
old Chevy yeah I think I had a shot I
had a Chevy too when I was growing up
you did I feel like everyone cool had a
Chevy growing up some kind of Chevy I
did I had a uh Corsica I'm looking that
up right now yeah I know was there a
Chevy Corsica looked at it there was
right please tell me that it's it's true
someone out there look make sure there's
a Chevy Corsica because I'm out I'm not
going to lose this this ad read just
because Sona went out on a Wire
and invented a Chevy that doesn't exist
I like the Chevy malt Blanc
there's no Montblanc
Chevy is on the line they want to talk
to you oh no that's the Corsica oh look
who is right oh no it's my Corsica
that's the Corsica right there
yes they can everyone's drooling they
want that too small they want that 80s
Corsica but my Corsica growing up was
great yeah and uh lasted forever well
guess what you wouldn't want a course
Canal you'd want an EV oh for sure you
know why I like the term EV it's my term
for electric vehicle uh that I came up
with you made that up I sure did on the
way in here and if Chevy's nice I'll let
them have it you can buy the bolt EV you
can buy the bolt euv oh that's uh
utility vehicle that's bigger I'm glad
you're here
you should be oh my God garbage just
read off oh my God my favorite name for
a truck Silverado my god I've always
wanted isn't that the best name it is
it's really cool ask me what I try Drive
hey Conan what do you drive Silverado
and learn more about the Equinox EV or
Equinox depends on where you live while
staying tuned for more info on Chevy's
vision for an electric future as I say
electronical future okay no one else
says that I'm an idiot yeah uh and what
was yours called a Chevy Corsica maybe
they'll bring it back maybe I mean you
know it was a really it honestly lasted
us forever it was and I think it was one
of I can't remember the other cars we
had but it was one of you know what if
we could if we can track down your old
Corsica I'll have it electrified no you
won't yes I will I'll have it
electrified why don't you just my
expense my personal expense hold on uh
Asterix Chevy May participant no can you
just buy me a new car no that's electric
but buy me the bolt euv no that's too
easy and not cool these are great these
cards are great but we're gonna find
your old Corsica and Electrify it you're
not getting one of these new babies
these are too nice for you to learn more
about the Chevy EV lineup head to
chevrolet.com Conan